hey friends so check this out this is a
POI hybrid specifically a combination of
a three- petal anti-spin flower mixed up
with an extension we usually call this
POI pattern the Mercedes and though I've
done many tutorials on this move in the
past I have just come up with what I
think is by far the easiest approach
that I have ever seen for getting this
trick down and I'm going to share it
with you in this
video
Drex here from Drex Factor po sharing
with you the love of Po spinning and
flow Arts to benefit your body and brain
and today we're going to get those
brains and bodies chugging on the
Mercedes which might just be the most
famous po move aside of course from the
three beat Weaver the buzs saw but
before we dive in I do just want to give
a quick shout out to the Friends of the
channel big thanks to dark monk fire
Mecca flow fests flow toys juggling
calling pyroar light toys spinballs and
Ultra poy for helping to make the videos
on this channel possible you can learn
more about all these awesome companies
and the work that they're doing to
support flow artists like yourself by
checking out the links down in the
description of this video and special
thanks to the non- business friend of
the channel Becca beonin thank you so
very much for supporting my channel my
work and my mission okay so quick
explanation here this is the PO Mercedes
with my left hand here I'm performing a
three pedal anti-spin flower that means
that as my hand is going around
counterclockwise relative to me the poy
is spinning around clockwise at the same
time I'm having my right hand perform an
extension this is a hybrid that is it's
the product of two dissimilar poy moves
being kind of grafted together into one
smooth continuous pattern uh and it is
also a poly Rhythm hybrid that is you
can see that there are two down beats in
the triat
that is two spots where the PO go
beneath my hand 1 2 1 2 and only one
spot where the PO in my right hand goes
beneath my hand just right there at the
bottom so it's kind of a cool
combination of shapes here because it
moves between two different timing and
Direction modes that is I am in together
opposites up top and I am in Split time
opposites down below and as it turns out
that is the key for this new method for
teaching this trick
so in the past I have used a variety of
different methods for teaching this
trick um one of my favorites has long
been to teach people how to do linear
extensions that is moving their hands
back and forth in a straight line as the
pois spin around them and then adding up
neighboring linear extensions if you
want to learn this way it takes a lot
longer but it does mean that you'll have
better technique I'll go ahead and link
to it down in the description um and of
course we've I've also talked extend Ely
about the weird things that happen with
the planes of the PO as you're going
through the Mercedes and yes we will
talk about in this one too but recently
I had a student who didn't have any of
that information under her belt and was
really keen on learning the Mercedes and
I found something kind of unexpected
that I could give her to put the pieces
together so the first step of this is
going to be to get really really really
comfortable with two different things
number one is going to be a thread the
needle or a butterfly that you perform
of course in together opposite
and the other one is going to be being
able to perform a split time butterfly
cuz you're going to need to switch back
and forth between these two things make
sure that you have these both really
well down in muscle memory because
otherwise the transitions between them
are going to be real rough so the first
thing we're going to want to do is tweak
our thread the needle just a little bit
namely we're going to kind of work on
making it bounce back and forth across
our body so basically every time you
have a new hand reaching over top you're
going to bring bring it to a stop over
on the side of your body uh this is what
it looks like from the side essentially
what I'm doing is every time I'm
bringing a new hand over top I'm
reaching over to the opposite side of my
body so every time it's my right hand
going over top I'm reaching over to the
left and every time it's my left hand
over top I'm reaching over to the right
I want to make sure that I'm getting as
far as I can from side to side as I'm
doing this and you're probably already
noticing that every time I'm reaching a
new hand over top the hand that's on
bottom is doing this funky thing where
it's already starting to look like an
anti-spin pedal a little bit H so once
this gets to feel pretty comfortable and
by pretty comfortable I mean you can go
back and forth 10 times without running
the PO into each other if you need some
help figuring out how to keep your uh
poy planes from running into each other
as you're doing the thread the needle
I've done a video on that topic that
I'll go ahead and link to up in the
cards as well as down in the description
but assuming that you have gotten this
part of it down it is now now time to
add the bottom part of the tri ketra
because you can think of this as the top
so what I'm going to do here is uh next
time my right hand goes over top boom
I'm just going to stop both of the PO
over here on my left side now both of
the PO are at a rest what I'm going to
do is I'm going to kind of reach my
index finger underneath my uh my my left
hand po here and I'm going to give it a
little bit of a flick as I bring both of
my hands back over to my right hand side
notice the left hand POI goes over both
hands but the right hand POI is still
hanging beneath both hands as I go
across in other words the PO split apart
as I'm heading back to my right okay so
what we're going to do then is come back
to our thread the needle here and we're
going to think that we're going to stop
on the left in
one
two three moves and then flick the left
hand point over going going back to the
right we're going to go back over
2 three times make it stop and bring the
left po over we're then going to work
our way down to only doing just
one two times across the top bring the
left hand over again
one two times across the top and bring
the left poy over now we're going to try
and just do one beat across the top and
then flick the left po over one beat
across the top flick the left po over
one beat across the top flick the left
po over um if you are like both my
student and I as you were working
through this there's going to be a
moment over here on the right where
there's going to be a little bit of
confusion in terms of like getting the
PO moving again where you want your
planes to be um you're going to want
that left hand here uh to be the PO
plane that is on bottom and the right
hand po plane to be the one that's on
top as you go back over to the left I'll
show you that here right quick so as I'm
going over it's my right hand on top my
left hand on bottom boom and then I move
back over to the right notice that I'm
switching from having my right hand in
front over here to having my left hand
in front over here and my left hand
remains on front slash on bottom until I
get back over to my left hand side here
so left in front still left in front
then right in front left in front still
left in front
right in front as I go around so this is
going to be very slow and very awkward
as you're first learning how to do it
and that's totally fine but as you get
to be more comfortable with this you can
try and take less time to pause when you
do both the stop over on the left hand
side as well as switching back to that
thread the needle SL butterfly going
over top like so you can try and make it
feel more continuous and as you get more
and more comfortable with this you you
can try and pick up the pace just a
little bit and voila before you know it
the Mercedes emerges pretty rad huh
things to watch out for as you're doing
this once again let's take a look at
what's happening with the planes here so
as I'm going over to the left hand side
again my uh right hand poy plane is
going to be in front of my left- hand
poy plane and then they switch to having
the left- hand po plane in front and the
right poy plane behind over on the right
here and then going across the top it is
my right hand on top so the PO plane at
the top is is kind of tilted back
towards me in this little X shape right
here so I've got the right hand po plane
tilted back towards me and then over
here I've got the right po plane kind of
pointed out a little bit away from me
and as I move across to the opposite
side I've got the left-and PO plane uh
pointed just a little bit away from me
so I'm kind of having to move my PO
planes around just a little bit as I'm
going around here to make sure that the
poy cannot run into each other and of
course once you learn this with the left
hand doing the three pedal anti-spin
flow you can also learn it with the
right hand doing the three- pedal
anti-spin flow here's how again if we go
back to our friend the thread the needle
that is bouncing back and forth across
the top here rather than pausing over on
our left- hand side we can instead pause
over here on the right hand side from
this position right here I reach my
index finger underneath the tether of
the right hand POI and flick it over top
as both of my hands reach back over to
the left again I can do so thread the
needle with the left hand coming over on
top heading back over to the right and
then flick the right hand po head over
top heading back to the left so I go
over top and flick over top and flick
until hey look at that my Mercedes has
emerged once again this time with the
opposite hand doing the anti-spin and of
course the really fun thing that comes
out of learning how to do the Mercedes
going both ways is that now we can
reverse the direction of the Mercedes
whenever we want to I highly recommend
doing that at either of those bottom
corners because that's a spot that we're
already kind of used to stopping in and
it creates a nice and cool POI pattern
in and of itself to switch back and
forth between the two far out huh
hopefully this has demystify one of my
favorite po patterns for you all out
there if you go ahead and learn this
please post video of yourself doing it
online and make sure to tag me I love
seeing people's hard work as they're
learning all these different poy tricks
so help me out in that regard be sure to
like comment share and subscribe to help
other people find this video and of
course to help my channel
[Music]
grow this video would not be possible
without the amazing support of all of my
backers on patreon thank you one and all
and particular I would like to give a
shout out to my flow patrons who are
listed on screen right now uh if you
like the videos that I produce teaching
people how to spin POI and uh all the
different techniques that I've
accumulated over the years uh and you'd
like to see me make more of them there
is an easy way that you can make that
happen and that is to head on over to
patreon and sign up the address to do
that is patreon.com slir Factor po
there's a array of awesome rewards that
are available there and even better
you'll be helping me out and bringing
poy to the whole wide world so go check
that out please and thank you and if
you'd like to check out a video I did on
five po tricks that are much easier to
learn than you might think I'm going to
go ahead and link to that on screen
right now as well as down in the
description thanks so much for watching
make sure to get out and flow today and
I'll see you with a new video real soon
take care now peace